I want to be Liza Koshi yeah no wait I
want to be Blogilates and 1000 there you
go guys a quick and easy workout for the
morning but I also want to be a cat
can't sleep 16 to 20 hours of day
I don't know about you but lately I
always want to be someone else everyone
just looks like their lives are so much
more fun and like technically I know
this isn't the case like everyone has
their own problems no matter how dope
their instace that it is that around
lately I look at my friends and it seems
like everyone's traveling to exotic
locations or doing cool projects or
getting married and having kids I'm sort
of feel left behind and whenever I get
into these deep dive spirals of
comparing my life to someone else's I
just feel so lonely and worthless and
like a giant waste of space and the
worst part is I know I'm doing this to
myself by the way you suck suck pretty
hard this tendency is so destructive and
unfortunately only you can get to the
point where you recognize like okay
alright this is bad I need to break this
habit now cuz this makes me miserable
and so I'm at this point again and I
probably will be at the future at some
point yeah forever
yay yes children our lives are a
constant battle of self management and
look you know what I'm gonna say you
know what the advice is but yes I will
acknowledge it can be so hard to live
life as nothing today as possible and be
present and only compare yourself to
your past self because that does require
pretty rigorous mental training I mean
it's a moment-to-moment decision
it's like actively stopping before you
get two hours into an
before you know what you are very
familiar with the entire venmo
transaction history of your crush but
I've been there I have made a lot of bad
decisions like a lot of them sometimes
my finger will even hover over the
Instagram app and I have all of my
social media apps in a folder labeled
don't do it but even then I will ask
myself are you sure you want to do this
this will probably not make you feel
good you feel bad right now and you're
just actively seeking a justification
for your bad okay shut the hell up now
and see what everyone's up to and sure
enough yeah you were right I feel
horrible I told you so but you know what
it's okay cuz sometimes you do need to
make the wrong decision so many times
that there's nothing left but to make
the right one so if you're feeling
terrible lately and the cause is that
you're constantly feeding yourself
stimulation of everyone's perfectly
curated lives and it seems like their
lives are much better than yours then
just go get a life ah stop watching
everyone on screen stop watching me
right now I mean the only cure for that
kind of envy is to be so engaged in your
own life that it doesn't even occur to
you to get a photo for the gram some of
the best nights of my life were so great
that it never occurred to me to get a
photo and it makes me a little sad but
it's also a good sign I'm Anna Akana
stay awesome got them all so if you've
ever wondered how I make my episodes
from concept to creation while I'm on
the road and without my crew you now can
know I had the pleasure of partnering
with Samsung to teach up-and-coming
comedian Terrance I pulled it up just
that from the monologues I'm Anna Akana
I'm Karen Sepulveda deliver your true to
the Clone cutaways hello how are you all
great thank you so much Karen and I shot
an entire episode on a note 9 you can
click on the link in my description to
watch my episode of make and see how to
create your own show guys oh they're
dead well like comment and subscribe if
you can I'm Cassie ho bye